the following table lists the values of
functions F and H and of their
derivatives F Prime and H prime for X is
equal to 3 so this is telling us when X
is equal to 3 the value of the function
is 6 f of 3 is 6 you could view it that
way H of 3 is 0 F prime of 3 is 6 and H
prime of 3 is 4
and now they want us to evaluate the
derivative with respect to X of the
product of f of X and H of X when X is
equal to 3 so one way you could view
this is if we viewed some function if we
viewed some function G of X G of X as
being equal to the product of f of X and
H of X this expression is the derivative
of G of X so we could write G prime of X
is equal to the derivative with respect
to X of f of X times H of X which is
what we see right here which is what we
want to evaluate at x equals 3 so we
essentially want to evaluate G prime of
3 this is what they're asking us to do
well to do that let's go first up here
let's just think about what it's doing
they're asking us to take the derivative
with respect to X of the product of two
functions that we have some information
about well if we're taking the praat the
derivative of the product of two
functions you could imagine that the
product rule could prove useful here so
I'm just going to restate the product
rule this is going to be equal to the
derivative of the first function f prime
of x times the second function no dirt
not taking its derivative plus the first
function not taking its derivative f of
X times the derivative of the second
function H prime of X so if you're
trying to find G prime of 3 well that's
just going to be F prime of 3 times H of
3 plus F of 3 times H prime of 3 and
lucky for us they give us what all of
these things evaluate to F prime of 3
right over here they tell us
F prime when X is equal to 3 is equal to
6 so this right over here is 6 H of 3
they
give us that 2h of 3 when X is 3 the
value of our function is zero so this is
zero so this first term is you can just
get six times zero which is going to be
zero but we'll get to that now F of
three F of three well the function when
X is equal to 3 y or the func F of 3 is
equal to 6 so that is 6 and then finally
the H prime evaluated 3 H prime of X
when X is equal to 3 H prime of X is
equal to 4 or you could say this is H
prime of 3 so this is 4 and so there you
have it this is going to evaluate to 6
times 0 which that's all just going to
be 0 plus 6 times 4 which is going to be
equal to 24 and we're done